la crise sanitaire du coc vie de 19 a eu
un impact conséquent sur cette
entreprise trappistes plaisir fruité a
vu son chiffre d'affaires baisser de
moitié pendant cette période
avant la crise la firme vendait environ
12 tonnes de fruits et de légumes par
semaine avec notamment des livraisons
destinées aux professionnels
aulas une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
effectivement puisque les entreprises
aujourd'hui nous sur la partie livraison
de l'entreprise compte plus de 1000
entreprises toutes les semaines en
fruits dans leurs locaux et
donc on a une baisse de 100 % on a tout
perdu pendant le confinement là il ya
des entreprises qui reprennent
progressivement mais encore l'été donc
on va dire il ya les entreprises
favorisent encore beaucoup le
télétravail pour rebondir et préserver
la trentaine d'emplois du site
l'entreprise a dû se diversifier pendant
la période de confinement en s'adaptant
notamment aux demandes de leurs nouveaux
clients et en renouvelant leur packaging
là où on s'est aussi améliorée c'est que
du coup maintenant on est en livraison
par le biais de smartphones donc il ya
on arrive à avoir une traçabilité sur la
livraison sans contact avec la clientèle
puisque maintenant la preuve de
livraison c'est une photo
aujourd'hui l'entreprise espère encore
booster son activité après cette période
difficile plaisir fruité devrait
s'étendre en septembre prochain
en ouvrant une nouvelle boutique à
versailles